[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be diving into the very
weird World of Harry Potter knockoff
novels now given the worldwide
popularity of the Harry Potter franchise
it shouldn't be surprising that it spark
a couple of knockoffs some of these
novels continue the story and blatantly
read use Rowling's characters While
others create their own original
characters that seem a little too
familiar but one thing is consistent
they're all hilariously bad as are the
naming conventions for said novels so
whether you're hungry for more Hogwarts
or just in need of a laugh today we're
going to be diving in and taking a look
at 10 of the most outrageous knockoffs
from around the world honestly the sheer
goal of some of these Publishers will
shock you I'll also be sure to throw in
some book passages where applicable
let's dive into it one Harry Potter and
the half-blooded relative Prince China
this unique rendition of Harry Potter
has the unique selling point of a title
that was likely translated to Chinese
translated back into English translated
back into Chinese and finally back to
English again enter qot School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry where unexpected
chaos ensues in this novel Harry becomes
tired of Hogwarts and decides to
transfer to Croots the very best School
of Witchcraft and Wizardry in Asia he
also has an interesting change of heart
succumbing to the Allure of the dark
side after arriving in Asia Harry picks
up new hobbies like oh I don't know
summoning evil creatures including one
oddly named little fatty Fortune as the
plot unfolds his fellow students from
Croots band together to ultimately
defeat their comrade eventually
resorting to giving him a physical
Beatdown this peculiar tale challenges
the the norm provoking thoughts on the
potential consequences of Harry
embracing darkness and raises questions
about altering beloved characters and
fan expectations in the series summoning
charms everybody was surprised summoning
was a kind of magic but under normal
circumstances Harry had only basic
skills in summoning low class monsters
however the black smoke that emerged
from his hand showed the monster
summoned by his art was at least some
senior magic Beast with special energy
how could he get a senior Beast out of
nowhere within only one month's time
nobody had ever heard of a magic Beast
named little fatty Fortune certainly no
one knew this was just a name that Harry
invented himself everybody was eager to
know how little fatty Fortune would
perform except for one person that was
endog two Tanya gr and the Magical
double Bas Russia shifting directions
completely this story no longer follows
Harry Potter but instead Tanya grter his
Russian counterpart in this novel grter
trades in a broomstick for double bass
and sports a prominent mole in her nose
instead of the iconic lightning bolt on
Harry's forehead however despite these
differences she remarkably resembles our
beloved boy wizard in many ways just
like Harry she resides in a cramped
cupboard within the dv's house and
tragically loses her parents to a wicked
sorceress named chuma Del tort
eventually she sets off to begin her
studies at TB Do's school for
behaviorally challenged young witches
and wizards where the magic truly begins
and being the very first novel out of a
14-part series this book truly does only
scratch the surface of Tanya gr's
magical adventures here's a peculiar
passage taking a look at derv Russia's
response to the derley certainly derv
also did not suspect that he was being
observed a large disgusting looking bird
gloomy disheveled with a long scruffy
neck on which there were almost no
feathers was observing him from the
eaves of the entrance the bird held in
its beak a photograph cut from a
magazine and was looking at it yes it
was the same Herman derv taken together
with his wife Nel and daughter Peppa at
the international suspenders exhibition
in the all Russia Exhibition Center
occasionally the bird lowered the
photograph onto a metal sheet and
started to compare meticulously the
present DV with the photograph at the
same time disgusting greenish lumps of
mucus dripped from the beak onto the
photograph three Harry Potter in Kolkata
India we've been to China we've been to
Russia and now we're heading all the way
to India Kolkata to be exact in this
clandestine tale which rolling in her
Publishers reluctantly suppressed
Harry's escapades in kcasa unfold set
immediately after Harry's defeat of
Voldemort in the Goblet of Fire Harry is
invited to Kolkata by a devoted fan
named John to graciously accept ing jont
tu's offer Harry hops on his broomstick
and heads to Kolkata where he finds
himself sharing the literary stage with
iconic figures like rabindranath tagor
and zagit Ray to get a sense of things
please enjoy the opening lines of this
literary Masterpiece hello my friend
where do you want me to come to Kolkata
yes I mean to Kolkata Kolkata where is
that right here where I live but that's
Kolkata yes but now the name has been
changed to Kolkata
spectacular amazingly however this book
along with another Indian knockoff
titled Harry Potter o parash pathar have
achieved remarkable success in West
Bengal dominating the best sellers lists
and proving to be the crowd favorites at
six District Book Fairs four porri Gata
and the stone philosopher bellarus enter
the realm of this Belarusian parody
where our cherished magical wizard boy
undergoes a captivating transformation
meet porata a rebellious figure who
swaps his broomstick for a roaring
motorcycle and ditches the conventional
wand for a formidable grenade launcher
this captivating series presents a
unique Twist on the Potter mythology
portraying pori as a techsavvy
individual navigating a world inhabited
by traditional magicians with four
published books to its name this
irresistible inversion of the Beloved
Saga offers a refreshing take on the
enchanting narrative five Harry Potter
and the leopard walk up to Dragon China
this particular knockoff manages to rip
off not just one but two popular book
series skillfully blending their
narratives when Harry the protagonist
gets caught in a sweet and sour rain he
ends up morphing into a plump and hairy
dwarf yep you heard me in his quest to
regain his magical abilities he forms an
unlikely alliance with a wizard named
Gandalf heard of him with the pair
embarking on a thrilling adventure in
search of a mystical ring effectively
the author took a bunch of scenes from
Lord of the Rings and cleverly
substituted tolk's characters with
familiar faces from the Harry Potter
Universe here's the first paragraph
Harry did not know how long this bath
would take when he would finally scrub
off that oily sticky layer of cake icing
for someone who had grown into a
cultured polite young man a layer of
sticky filth really made him feel sick
he lay in the highquality porcelain tub
ceaselessly wiping his face in his
thoughts there was nothing but Dudley's
fat face fat as his aunt Petunia's fat
rear end six Harry Potter and the big
funnel AKA Harry Potter and the filler
of big China life takes an awkward turn
for Harry at the desley house when
Dudley starts dating a belly dancer
meanwhile fresh out of Hogwarts and
eager to embark on a new Adventure Harry
accepts an internship position at
Honiton school another Whiting
institution just as he is about to start
his new job however Harry receives a
warning from bat bug a Chinese version
of Dobby the house elf leaving him
uneasy about the impending trouble and
the potential danger he may face and
just as bat bug had warned him things
were not right at Honiton School within
the school's halls and unimaginable
horror unfolds as the students undergo a
dreadful transformation one by one they
are transformed into wooden stools
determined to solve the mystery Harry
Narrows down his list of suspects to an
evil student Hagrid Voldemort and the
enigmatic figure known as the filler of
big referred to as the big funnel while
the exact details of the story remain
unknown it is safe to assume that the
funnel plays a significant role in The
Peculiar events that unfold seven Harry
Potter and the Chinese porcelain doll
China our hero Harry Ventures to Asia
upon discovering that Voldemort is
aiming to Rally his Chinese follower
yand demort to conquer the Western
witing realm to thwart this treacherous
Duo Harry requires a Chinese porcelain
doll the sole item that may put an end
to their plans as Harry Journeys to
China he crosses paths with long long
and zing zing members of a Chinese
circus that yort used to work for as
naughty bubble Voldemort killed naughty
bubble's mother big spinach and
persuaded the boy into learning evil
magic Harry befriends the circus members
who hold the key to getting closer to
yander Mor and the doll Voldemort
nicknamed the mysterious man also
travels to China to recruit yandt to
defeat Harry Harry discovers this scheme
and rushes to find the doll while trying
to evade Voldemort's allies can Harry
and the Chinese circus acrobats locate
the doll in time to stop the Morts and
will naughty bubble seek revenge on
Voldemort upon realizing he killed big
spinach eight Tanya C and the golden
leech Russia going all the way back to
Russia let's Explore More Adventures of
Tanya grter Harry's double bass riding
mold sporting Russian counterpart in
this third installment of the series gr
finds herself taking on hurry pooper
sound familiar in the world Dragon Ball
championship in pursuit of the snitch
they ended up crashing into each other
unintentionally resulting in the
creation of an alternate timeline in
this altered reality the wicked chuma
Del tort remember him has triumphed over
the Wizarding World as a consequence the
inhabit ANS of this dystopian realm
communicate using a language similar to
orwellian newp but in Russian form in
order to restore normaly Tanya is tasked
with defeating the golden Lee a
mysterious entity that potentially
represents American capitalism though
its symbolism remains ambiguous in case
my summary didn't do the book any
justice here's a brief excerted from the
Publishers description Thunder shakes
The Magic School Tibido lightning be at
exactly one point the masonry on the
roof of the big tower and in the
neglected Gate House by the swamp T gr
discovers the Forgotten Prophecy of the
Ancient One if an ancient spirit is
released the golden leech will begin to
crawl into the magic fire and the rope
in the fingerboard of the double base
will break time will swing in the
opposite direction the revived Pagan
Idols will go to war on the Tores of
Eternity and the Sinister Gates will
collapse we wouldn't want that now would
we nine Harry Potter and the Chinese
overseas students at Hogwart School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry China with
Voldemort's increasing power Dumbledore
takes proactive measures to safeguard
Hogwarts in order to fortify the school
he enlists the assistance of six
exceptionally gifted Chinese students
known for their Brilliance and diligent
work ethic their presence serves as
inspiration for the Hogwart students as
they confront Voldemort and his
formidable army of DeMent ERS werewolves
Giants and Death Eaters during a large
scale assault 10 Harry Potter and The
Showdown China I like the idea of this
one a lot because it doesn't introduce a
mass of new characters or try to turn
the books into something else alog
together there's an obvious effort to
stay true to the source material and
simply take the story in a new but
somewhat consistent Direction after
Dumbledore's death mcgonagle and slug
horn take charge of reopening Hogwarts
Joe Chang introduces the students to an
Asian Spell comp ium known as 36
strategies to combat the still evil
Snape in this alternate conclusion The
Narrative takes an unpredictable twist
when mcgonagal meets her demise at the
hands of the Sword of Gryffindor Harry
ultimately faces Voldemort at aaban and
successfully slays him however the
conclusion is a real Cliffhanger Harry
is stuck in an unresolved love triangle
and on that note I think that's enough
fake Harry Potter for today I just hope
you enjoyed that as much as I did I
should also mention that unfortunately
you're unlikely to be able to get your
hands on any of these works as JK
Rowling and her Publishers have launched
an aggressive worldwide legal campaign
against the unauthorized Potter
spin-offs I suppose you can't really
blame them there are more ripoffs out
there so if you'd like another video on
this then please do let me know if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live